[Musique]
merci d'être toujours avec nous sur tv
60,18 bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez
tv 78 délocalisent toute la journée son
antenne aux pyramides de port marly où
se tiennent les universités des mairies
des yvelines objectif zéro carbone c'est
l'ambition affichée par plusieurs
grandes villes du monde dont paris un
engagement pris au sommet de san
francisco c'était en septembre dernier
une centaine de grandes villes vise une
suppression totale des gaz à effet de
serre et ce en 2050 alors une ville
totalement neutre en carbone d'ici
quelques années projet utopiste ou
réaliste pour y répondre mon invité un
seul invité pour ce débat en plateau
jérôme arnaud disent bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes le directeur du pôle erp
de suez vous allez nous dire comment
suez s'engage dans la lutte contre la
pollution atmosphérique et le
réchauffement climatique et notamment à
travers l'exemple du puits de carbone
que vous avez installé depuis mai à
poissy parlez-nous justement d'abord de
ce pôle erp suez qu'est ce que ce pôle
est et quelles sont ses missions
alors le pôle sur le pôle erp de suez et
apporte aux que ce soit aux
collectivités ou aux industries une
expertise et des solutions sur tout sur
sur toutes les problématiques liées à
l'air au réchauffement climatique ça
peut aller de la quantification des
problèmes jusqu'au traitement mais
également aussi au suivi en temps réel
de ce que ce soit pollution
atmosphérique ou les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans un instant de sexe
et cet exemple de travail le cuir
carbone alors je vous pose d'emblée la
question on va on se positionne en 2050
c'est demain finalement est ce que dira
une ville totalement neutres en carbone
est ce que vous y croyez ou est ce que
c'est un objectif finalement
inatteignable d'après vous alors soyons
clairs c'est vrai que cet objectif est
très ambitieux mais il est également
nécessaire
aujourd'hui il y a urgence
d'accélérer pour tenir les objectifs de
la coop 21 de paris et de limiter la
hausse du réchauffement climatique à 2
degrés donc vous aviez vis-à-vis de
cette urgence d'accélérer cet objectif
est important primordial aujourd'hui feu
se fixer cet objectif qui peut paraître
radicales c'est à dire être à zéro
carbone en 2050 où vous le disiez
peut-être d'abord dans un premier temps
se fixer des limites à ne pas dépasser
les 2 degrés que vous évoquez des
limites aussi sur des particules fines a
à ne pas franchir que dans quel axe il
faut se positionner
alors c'est vrai que des limites plus
court terme permettent de quantifier et
de mesurer les packs l'ont franchie et
que l'on les progrès que l'on fait tous
les jours tous les ans par contre 7,9
cet objectif en 2050 et lui important
parce qu'il fixe un cap et ce cap là est
important puisque l'action elle n'est
pas que local elle est tout le monde en
fait ne peut et doit agir
que ce soit les collectivités
territoriales l'état les entreprises et
aussi les citoyens
aujourd'hui cet enjeu de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique il est
totalement pris en compte par votre pôle
erp aller de suez alors oui le pôle le
pôle sueur le pôle erp de suez est
justement là pour apporter accompagné
que ce soit les clients que l'activité
mais également les industrielles et même
parfois on le voit les citoyens qui nous
pose beaucoup de questions notamment sur
cette innovation de puits de carbone
donc on est là pour accompagner pour
être de proposer une ou plusieurs
solutions
puisqu'on le sait c'est ce que j'ai dit
juste avant c'est un panel de solutions
qui permettra d'atteindre ses objectifs
ambitieux l'une de ces solutions
justement vous l'avez inauguré en mai
dernier à poissy un puits de carbone
alors c'est une innovation pour lutter
contre la pollution atmosphérique et le
réchauffement climatique regarder ce
sujet réalisé à l'époque par michael et
demi d'euros le quartier de la gare de
poissy devrait à mieux respirer la ville
a inauguré ce mercredi 22 mai un puits
de carbone le premier des yvelines
objectif de ce dispositif lancé après
deux ans d'expérimentation lutter contre
la pollution atmosphérique et notamment
le co2 dégagées par les voitures
le principe est le principe de la
photosynthèse on prend de l'air vicié
que l'on injecte dans la colonne dans
cette colonne nous avons mis de l'eau et
des microalgues que nous éclairons
continue et le fait de combiner les
clairement plus pollution d'un air vicié
les micro algues vont capter cet air
vicié se reproduire et purifier l'air
ainsi le totem de deux mètres cinquante
a été loué par la ville de poissy
jusqu'à l'année prochaine pour une
période de test coût total de
l'opération à 20000 euros la commune
espère également sensibiliser les
passants sur l'environnement nous
aimerions que les gens se posent la
question parce qu'un aspect pédagogique
qui est très important pour nous qu'il
se dise bah tiens il ya peut-être des
solutions au niveau du développement
durable au niveau de la défense de
l'environnement et qu'ils prennent
conscience de tous les enjeux
si l'expérience est concluante sur cette
première année le puits de carbone
devrait être renouvelée à part la ville
un sujet de mickaël millero alors on
vous a vu dans ce sujet jérôme arnaud 10
expliquez-nous ce principe de puits de
carbone à nos téléspectateurs alors le
puis on l'a compris captent le co2 il
capte aussi les les particules fines et
le dioxyde d azote grâce aux algues
c'est à dire que là il ya un gros
pouvoir de dépollution oui tout à fait
en fait on ne fait que reproduire ce qui
se passe dans les océans ou dans les
rivières ou les lacs
par contre quand le l'optimisme on
essaye de l'accélérer et surtout en leu
leu on le met en oeuvre dans un
environnement urbain
là où on en a besoin finalement comment
ça fonctionne la photosynthèse sociaux
c'est ce principe qui est utilisé dans
ce puits de carbone exactement donc en
fait on va chercher des microalgues on
s'est associé à une société qui
s'appelle fermentalg qui est un
spécialiste des microalgues français
basé à côté de bordeaux à libourne on
sélectionne avec eux des touches de
micro algues en fonction du cas
d'application et la photosynthèse en
fait c'est un phénomène qu'utiliser le
micro algues donc elle utilise la
lumière pour capter le co2 et d'autres
polluants atmosphériques et le
transformer en fait en biomasse est à
dire qu'elle se reproduise avec ce co2
et elles produisent également à chaque
chaque molécule de co2 capté
les microalgues fabrique une molécule
d'oxygène 1 puis comme celui installé à
poissy vous comptez le l'installer dans
d'autres villes en france
alors oui c'est une innovation qu'on a
développée il ya deux ans on le
développe un petit peu à la main d'une
start up c'est à dire que dès que le
produit est prêt on le propose à nos
collectivités à nos clients clients à
nos clients industriels également donc
aux clients collectivités et industriels
c'est quelque chose qui plaît beaucoup
donc on essaye de répondre à la demande
tant terme d'expérimentation sur de
nouvelles applications que des
démonstrations urbain comme c'est le cas
voici l'eau qui ressort de ses pieds si
on continue expliqué ce principe elle
est ensuite revalorisé c'est ça voilà
exactement en recyclant fait les micro
algues quand elles captent le co2 et la
pollution
elles se reproduisent on les extraits
périodiquement et on les envoie dans des
stations d'épuration via les réseaux
d'assainissement existant est arrivée en
station d'épuration c'est là toute la
magie de la chose elles sont les
transforme en méthane en biométhane en
biogaz
donc ce biogaz ensuite qui est
totalement ouvert on peut l'utiliser
soit sur la station d'épuration soit le
réinjectée sur le réseau de gaz de ville
comme ça peut être le cas par exemple à
strasbourg et sur la quantité d'air a
absorbé par le pion nez sur quel ordre
de volume alors alors à l'échelle d'une
année on va être sur quelques tonnes de
co2 ça peut aller sur des centaines de
tonnes de co2 en fonction de la taille
du dispositif
là encore c'est un de nos enjeux comme
je vous le disais on développe comme une
start up et lila l'enjeu sur 2019 ça va
être pouvoir répondre à la demande avec
des dés et des équipements de plus en
plus grands on l'a dit il est installé
en mai dernier à poissy c'est une
expérimentation qui est menée sur
plusieurs mois est ce que vous avez
d'ores et déjà des premiers résultats
sur sur ce que terrebonne sur l'utilité
de ce puits de carbone alors poissy a
été effectivement de noms de nos
collectivités pionnières puisque c'est
c'est la première qui a décidé de mettre
ce dispositif de démonstrateurs urbain
en place les essais sont sont bien
évidemment en cours
je pourrais pas trop en parler
puisqu'ils vont durer un an d'accord ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que les
attaques et les résultats sont en ligne
avec nos déjà dans expérimentation passé
ça a été dit également dans le reportage
ce qui est installé face à la gare rer
de poids si tout le monde ne peut le
voir tous les passants il ya un rôle
aussi pédagogique cessé d'expliquer
aussi cet enjeu de de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique aux gens qui se
baladent dans la rue oui tout à fait et
ça fonctionne plutôt très très bien
passé les gens s'arrêtent pose les
questions
alors on a des explicatifs sur le sur le
sur l'habillage urbain que l'on met
autour de ce dispositif
mais c'est vrai que les sages génère
beaucoup de questions que les gens sont
positivement intrigué ça veut dire que
le pôle erp de suez suez plus
globalement au 6e se place dans cette
démarche de d'inciter les populations
peut être à changer les leur
comportement oui tout à fait alors suez
depuis depuis maintenant quelques années
a changé son business model vers une
dizaine mandats liés à l'économie
circulaire
tous nos projets en interne sont évalués
à justement avec cette ce prisme là je
vais prendre un exemple tout récent avec
l' usine de pour mars chocolat france
celle usine qui fabrique les m and m's
pour l'europe est en fait on la relier à
une unité de valorisation énergétique
d'haguenau et ça permet en fait de
l'alimenter l' usine de fabrication des
ménages vapeur verte est pour comme ça
on a permis de leur réduire leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 60
%
allez on va refermer cet entretien est
une question plus ouverte
comment se donne les moyens aujourd'hui
d'aller vers cette ville zéro carbone
cette ville espérait zéro carbone en
termes de transport mais aussi en termes
d'énergie par exemple alors il faut une
mobilisation de tous chacun peut agir et
je pense que c'est c'est le message
important
pour vos téléspectatrices et
téléspectateurs tout le monde peut agir
et les solutions elles sont à la portée
de tout le monde
merci et jérôme arnaud 10 d'avoir été
avec nous merci à vous je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur du pôle f2 suez
restez avec nous sur tv 60,18 nos
émissions spéciales continue depuis à
les pyramides de porc marlier aux
universités à des mairies dans un
instant nicolas d'andry et ses invités
répondront à une question fallait-il
supprimer la taxe d'habitation c'est à
suivre dans quelques minutes belle
journée avec tv 78
[Musique]